THE PUCK COMES DOWN TO THEIR
ZONE OFF,
THE ICING IS AS THAT BECOMES
AKES SURE
HIS MOMENTUM DOE LANE
DRIVE, THAT'S WHAT YOU WANT TO
SEE ESPECIALLY EARLY, ESTABLISH
THE SPACING, JARRET STOLL RED L
H TRAFFIC KIN
SAMSONOV.
>> Jim: ONE THING WITH THE
CAPITALSADRIAN KEMPE WITH A CAN.
>> Jim: HE TALKEDD ACROSS, ROY
BJORNFOT, 1 ON
THE POWER PLAY.
SO ONE FACE- THEY BLEW IT
BUT THEN THEY
MINUTE.
>> Jim: WE TALKED ABOUT IT
EA TYPE OF PATIENCE
IF NOTHING JENSEN, BACK PASS,
REASON WHY HE'S HAD TO CHANGE
HIS GAME UP A BIT. BEHERE.
>> Alex: BANKED
GIVE ADRIAN CREDIT.
IT'S UNDER RAT
15-SECOND SPAN.
>> Jim: WITH SAMSONOV THERE, HE
COCO -- I
WOULDN'T GO AS FAR T
SAVE QUICK.
JENSEN PUCK LODGED IN HIS
SKATES. PLAY.
KUZNETSOV LOCKS UP WITH DANAULT-
REDIRECT WITH OVECHKIN AND
THE CAPITALS
CLAGUE, WHIPS IT AROUND THE
BOARDS OUT OF THE REACH OF
ELEVATE AND YOU CAN SEE THAT ONE
PUSH AND EXTENDING THE PASS IN
THE WAY.
OVECHKIN SIDE STEPS ANDERSON, H.
SO EFFECTIVE, SO EFFICIENT IN
THAT  AREA.
THE BREAKOUT PASSES. QUICK AND
FROM McMICHAEL.
>> FROM
KINGS.
>> Alex: DELAYED
OF THE CIRCLE EXCHANGE ON THE
IS ON THE
GREATCORNER, EXCHANGES WITH THE
ACTIVATING CLAGUE, CLAGUE
CENTERING PASS, KEMPE HADOOTING
PERFECT SOUTH, CAPITALS GET TO
THE PUERREACTING, ALL THE WAY
ACROSS, WATCH THIS, RIGHT BACK.
GOES AFTER ORLOV WITH A HEAVY
ARVIDSSON, ONE-TIMER KEMPE UP T